bonjour à toutes et à tous ces paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux alors évidemment la news de ces
derniers jours ça a été la découverte de
la queue de spinosaurus qui démontrerait
qu'il est qu'il était finalement
complètement aquatique
évidemment nous avons fait une vidéo à
part pour vous parler de ça donc nous
n'allons pas parler aujourd'hui de
spinosaurus qui a pourtant fait la
couverture de nageur mais nous allons
parler de tout ce qui se cache derrière
spinosaurus à savoir tous les trucs qui
sont passées complètement sous le radar
à cause du raz-de-marée médiatique qu'a
causé la découverte de spinosaurus parce
qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de choses
intéressantes qui ont été découvertes du
moins publié en même temps que
spinosaurus que la queue de spinosaurus
est évidemment elles se sont toutes fait
dévorer tout cru par le géant
le géant médiatique qu'est spinosaurus
parce que tous ne tout n'a pas
évidemment l' avantage d'avoir été
popularisé par jurassic park
donc on va commencer par ceux cet
article article qui a été publié dans la
revue paléo 3 donc pas les honteux le
paléo géographie paléoclimatologie et
paléoécologie qui n'est pas encore
publiée en réalité puisqu'il n'a été que
accepter ce qui veut dire qu'en gros ce
que je vais vous montrer aujourd'hui
basse et l'homme c'est la version
manuscrite mais dans le contenu a été
pire review v et a été acceptée par les
pires review vert et par les éditeurs
donc en fait le contenu restera le même
c'est juste la mise en page qui va
changer quand il sera publié donc c'est
ce qu'on appelle une pré proof une pré
épreuve si vous voulez et hank cet
article il nous parle des raptor et du
fait que les raptor ne chassez pas en
meute et ça ça fait partie des gros idée
mais qu'ils ont bien la vie dure alors
que deux bases la plupart des gens ne
savent même pas d'où elles sortent pour
pas dire qu'elles sont carrément sorti
de nulle part
1 et donc ce que j'aime bien avec cet
article est basse et qui commence déjà
par nous rappeler un petit historique de
housses or l'idée et ça c'est quand même
vachement bien donc l'idée de l'idée que
les raptor chasser en meute ça vient pas
de nulle part ça vient d'eux
la découverte de ce que l'aide de
détonique us ou du moins de restes
fossilisés de détonique us qui sent
souvent mélangés c'est le mot qu'ils
emploient mélangé avec ténontosaure us
steel éthique qui est un ornithologue
donc proche de l'iguane aux dons et
ténontosaure us steel et y du coup est
une proie bien plus grosse que des
nonick us et donc trouver plein de
petits dés nonick us autour d'un goûter
nom taurus et bien ça ça te suggère
fortement que les démonique us s'ils
mettaient à plusieurs pour pouvoir tuer
ténontosaure us d'où découlent l'idée
que des nonick us chasser en meute comme
un loup mais chasseurs en mode comme
elle ou sa applique une grande cohésion
sociale et ça implique des stratégies
donc ça applique sa applique une vie ça
implique beaucoup d'autres processus
on va dire beaucoup d'autres processus
intellectuel que simplement de chasser
en troupeau enfin en meute donc donc
ostrom il a proposé ça en 1969 sur la
base de deux des nonick us qui avait été
retrouvé avec du thé nom taurus
découvertes qui ont été renouvelés
depuis on a retrouvé d'autres
ténontosaure us avec plein d'ennemis cus
autour mais la grande question c'est
enfin mais là où il faut déjà être
sceptique c'est sur le côté est ce qu'il
n'ya pas d'autre moyen d'avoir plein de
détonique us regroupé avec un
ténontosaure us par exemple on sait que
des chasseurs éminemment solitaire comme
les crocodiles
s'il ya suffisamment à manger ils
peuvent s'y mettre à plusieurs il n'y a
pas de souci ça veut pas dire qu'ils ont
coopéré pour m pour tuer la proie ça
veut juste dire que voilà il y avait
assez à manger pour tout le monde et
puis voilà et puis quand bien même la
proie
sylla poids est assez grosse et qui en a
un qu'il l'attrapait que du coup elle
est affaiblie bas il y en a un autre qui
va venir pour simplement pour avoir sa
part du gâteau
même si la proie est pas encore morte et
pourtant c'est des chasseurs éminemment
solitaire et c'est pareil pour les
varans de komodo les varans de komodo
sur des chasseurs solitaire mais ça les
empêche pas de s'y mettre à plusieurs
quand il est quand il a suffisamment à
manger pour tout le monde donc c'est pas
fort et c'est pas une coopération voulue
on va dire c'est une c juste voilà de
l'opportunisme donc trouver plein de
dénis cus tous ensemble
ça veut pas forcément dire que les dés
nonick us chasser ensemble ça veut dire
qu'ils ont mangé ensemble et si vous
avez vraiment très très envie de
surinterpréter le registre fossile
j'ai même envie de dire trouver des
démonistes tous ensemble qui sont morts
tous ensemble ça veut dire qu'ils
étaient vraiment pas doué à chasser
ensemble
bah oui ils sont morts et oui ils sont
morts ils sont fossilisés donc ils sont
morts et s'ils sont morts en groupe
c'est qu'ils étaient nuls à le faire
c'est qu'ils étaient nuls à être
ensemble
donc voilà on peut on peut
surinterpréter beaucoup d'échos
occurrence de prédateurs ou alors on
peut tacher d'avoir un petit peu du un
petit peu de recul
là dessus et de se dire bas que l est
des fois le la coopération opportunisme
opportuniste ça existe et on peut se
dire aussi ma foi que les pièges à
prédateurs ça existe et rappelez-vous
piège à prédateurs piège à couillons ça
veut pas dire qu'ils chasser en meute
les pièges à prédateurs ça veut dire que
d'une façon ou d'une autre il ya une
proie qui s'est retrouvé coincé quelque
part que les prédateurs sont venus que
ces crétins de prédateurs se sont aussi
retrouvés coincés par exemple si c'est
de la boue ou dut ou du bitume comme à
rancho la brea est que les prédateurs
mourant ou aussi attirer d'autres
prédateurs et puis à la fin vous vous
retrouvez avec 200 prédateurs autour
d'une proie et ça veut pas dire qu'ils
s'y sont mis à deux sens pour la
flinguer la proie ça veut juste dire
qu'ils se sont tous retrouvés coincés
comme des glandus donc voilà donc il
faut être assez perplexe quand on vous
propose des interprétations des
surinterprétations du registre fossile
en mode a il était à plusieurs c'est
qu'ils chassaient en meute non c'est
trop c'est simple voire simpliste et
autant ça paraît une solution élégante
comme proposé ostrom je dire ce n'est
pas le dernier des couillons celle-là
dinosaures renaissance c'est lui quoi
mais mais voilà autant c'est pas le
dernier des couillons autant c'est une
interprétation qui reste assez voilà on
trouve plein de fossiles c'est une
possibilité trouve plein de détonique us
c'est possible qu'ils chassaient en
troupeau ça aurait du sens dans la
mesure où ils sont petits et ou telle
honte aux eaux russes est plutôt gros
par rapport à voilà mais mais mais mais
du coup comment comment on fait pour
démontrer finalement un comportement
social dans le registre fossile et ça
c'est quelque chose qui est assez
compliquée notamment quand il s'agit de
démontrer que des animaux chassent en
meute
comment vous démontrer que des animaux
chassent en meute avec des fossiles bas
la réponse c'est que c'est quasiment
impossible
c'est quasiment impossible à moins
d'avoir des traces fossiles donc des
empreintes de pas fossile d'une proie
traqué par les chasseurs et ça à ma
connaissance n'est arrivé qu'une fois
avec des hommes c'est d'être à sedan pas
des empreintes de pas d'homme moderne
qui date de dix mille ans je crois de
dix minutes treize mille ans en amérique
du nord dans le sable on voit des
empreintes d'homme moderne qui suivent
des empreintes de pas d'un paresseux
géant et même là j'ai envie de dire je
crois pas qu'ils aient trouvé à la fal
le je crois pas que le lieu où ils ont
mis la bête où ils ont tué la bête se
trouve à primer dans le sable donc même
là vous pouvez juste dire soit ils
suivaient à paresseux géant soit soit
ils sont passés longtemps après apparaît
ce géant finalement serbe
enfin je veux dire même si les
empreintes de pas ont été faits juste
deux heures après le passage du
paresseux géant
bah voila je vais dire ça prouvait rien
donc
donc voilà on peut on a des fossiles qui
permettent raisonnablement de
de d'estimer qu'il puisse y avoir chasse
en groupe chasse coordonnées mais voilà
et puis là en plus je parle d' homo
sapiens c'est à dire une espèce dont on
sait qu'ils chassent en groupe ce qui
n'est pas le cas de denon xd nonick us
il appartient aux archosaures et les
archosaures la chasse en groupe c'est
quand même pas exactement leur leurs
rayons quoi les crocodiles vous laissez
tomber en gros et puis les puis chez les
oiseaux il ya ya ya les buses de harris
via les buses de harris qui chassent en
groupe et puis s'ils vont trouver un
autre bah merci parce que voilà ça fait
une espèce sur 15000 voilà si on compte
ouais non sur 10000 à les toits sont
sait pas exactement combien il ya
d'espèces d'oiseaux on en connaît au
moins 10000 donc ça fait une espèce sur
dix mille dards cause or qui chassent en
meute
donc bon démonique us il est quand même
mal barré pour être chasse en meute un
de bazin il est pas il n'a pas il n'a
pas le bagage qu'il faut donc on a
raison d'être sceptique face à ça et
donc cet article eh ben il nous propose
une vision critique de ça
et notamment en faisant déjà comme je
disais à un petit une petite review de
ce qui a été publié donc déjà d'où sort
l'idée et puis les gens qui en ont fait
des des critiques donc par exemple
l'ofce brickman en 2007 qui qui ont
trouvé en fait des fossiles de détonique
aux eaux russes qui ont de détonique us
pardon qui ont été mordiller par
d'autres des nonistes us donc ça niveau
niveau comportement social ses moyens
ses moyens pour disons qu'une espèce
social a pas trop tendance à bouffer
c'est qu'on spécifiques comme y disent
mais bon admettons c'est le cannibalisme
n'est pas exclu chez les espèces qui
vivent en société donc pourquoi pas et
puis bah à côté de ça on a des espèces
des des espèces bien connu qui qui sont
qui sont des chasseurs solitaire donc
comment on prouve que dès que des
fossiles des espèces éteintes chasser en
meute donc un comportement tout à fait
non fossiles is able ben euh ils se sont
intéressés aux isotopes c'est à dire
qu'ils ont fait des analyses
géochimiques et ils ont trouvé et là je
vais devoir scrollé jusqu'en bas pour
vous montrer les images en fait en
faisant des analyses chimiques
géochimiques de la composition des eaux
ils ont trouvé que les juvéniles les
bébés monique us avait une signature
géochimique très différente des adultes
des nonick us alors qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire
déjà au niveau de la signature
géochimique qu'est ce qu'on regarde bas
on regarde en fait la composition
chimique des dents dont ils ont pris des
dans des petites dante démonique us des
grandes-ventes démonique us en faisant
bien gaffe et finalement que ce soit la
même espèce et sur ses dents en fait ils
ont regardé la composition chimique et
on sait que la composition chimique des
eaux des dents et enfin de tout ce qui
fait votre corps dépend de la
composition chimique de ce que vous
mangez et ils viennent
ivan notamment y avoir les isotopes du
carbone des isotopes du carbone le
carbone c'est l'élément principal de
tout tissu biologique donc on est à peu
près sûr d'en trouver déjà donc c'est
davantage du carbone et de deux
avantages du carbone c'est que c'est
directement de notre bout
qu'on le sort le carbone c'est pas comme
par exemple si on prenait les les
isotopes je sais pas moi de l'oxygène
par exemple les isotopes de l'oxygène en
les tirs de l'eau qu'on boit donc ça
nous indique pas grand chose sur ce
conte sur ce qu'on mange quoi donc les
isotopes du carbone par contre on les
tire directement de notre nourriture et
donc c'est en fonction des isotopes du
carbone que vous mangez pas différents
isotopes du carbone vont se fixer dans
vos dents donc les isotopes du carbone y
en a plusieurs les plus connus c'est
carbone 12 donc le carbone normal j'ai
envie de dire le carbone 13 celui qu'ils
ont regardé en pourcentage du carbone 12
est il ya le carbone 14
qu'on utilise pour dater parce qu'il est
radioactif bon carbone 14 il est un film
vous avez du carbone 14 mai dans votre
corps mais vous ne rêvez pas assez pour
vous irradiés ne vous en faites pas donc
le carbone
là ils ont regardé le carbone 13 parce
que le carbone 13 à quelque chose de
très intéressant en fait c'est que il
il est c'est la variante lourds du
carbone du carbone le carbone 12 c'est
la variante légère et du coup cette
variante lourdes va s'accumuler dans la
chaîne alimentaire
ce qui veut dire que plus vous mangez
quelque chose qui est lui-même
carnivores en fait plus vous allez
accumulé de carbone 13 donc un carnivore
qui mange un carnivore qui mange un
carnivore
ça va finir par accumulé beaucoup de
carbone 13 alors qu un carnivore qui
s'attaque directement à un herbivore
comme tes notes aux russes lui par
contre il va pas avoir beaucoup de
carbone 13
et justement c'est ce que nous montre
ces ces graphes ce que nous montre c'est
grave c'est que les adultes s'attaquer
directement aux herbivores car ils ont
moins de carbone 13 que les juvéniles
qui eux s'attaquer à d'autres carnivores
alors s'attaquer à d'autres carnivores
ça veut pas dire qu'ils attaquaient des
tirs ex1 ça veut dire qu'ils attaquaient
des petits lézards qui mangeaient eux
mêmes des insectes qui mangent eux mêmes
des plantes
voilà donc on est déjà sur le troisième
niveau de la chaîne trophique de la
pyramide
si vous préférez de la chaîne
alimentaire dont ils mangeaient des
petits lézards qui mangeaient eux mêmes
des insectes où il mangeait des petits
mammifères qui mangeaient eux mêmes des
insectes où ils pouvaient aussi manger
des insectes qui mangeait eux mêmes d
insectes ou des araignées qui mangeaient
d un break vous avez l'idée il mangeait
des trucs qui était déjà eux-mêmes
carnivores et ses trucs et est
probablement très petit parce que c'est
des bébés 1 le dire c'est des bd noni
cul s'il pouvait pas non plus attaquer
ad comme je disais que ce serait
ridicule de s'imaginer qu'ils mangeaient
des carnivores plus gros qu'eux donc et
et ils ont fait ça sur deux sites donc
de deux types de deux gisements en
classe formée shon et clova clover leaf
formation et sur ces deux gisements ils
ont trouvé que les deux signature
géochimique celle des petits et celle
des adultes étaient différentes et on
trouve la même chose chez les crocodiles
chez les crocodiles la signature des
juvéniles est différente de la signature
des adultes ils ont fait ça sur les
crocodiles moderne mais ils ont fait ça
aussi sur des crocodiles qui date de la
même époque que les dés de nick us pour
voir si justement la différence n'était
pas dû à un billet géologique et bien
confirmation ce n'est pas un billet
géologique et ça veut dire que les bébés
démonique us ne mangeait pas la même
chose que les adultes démonique us et ça
veut dire que les adultes démonique us
ne nourrissait pas leurs petits donc il
n'ya pas deux ans fin du mois du moins
pas les petits qui avaient des dents
bien formés et donc ça veut dire que les
adultes avaient un niveau de soins
parental extrêmement bas donc on était
face à des petits qui est sondhi n'y
diffuse comme les canards et comme les
autruches donc ni diffuse ça veut dire
que les petits ils éclosent ice bar et
ils sont plus ou moins autonomes alors
après les adultes peuvent plus ou moins
les aider ça veut pas dire qu'il ya zéro
soit parentaux notamment chez des mots
ni cu sur satan en tant que parent a
bien que dinosaures parra vient groupe
frère des oiseaux on s'attendrait quand
même à ce qu'il ait un minimum de soins
parental d'autant qu'on sait que les
laits drôme et aux orres couver leurs
oeufs mais mais quand même le soin
parentale était très limité et
et ne comprenait pas le nourrissage des
petits ce qui veut dire que l'un des
attributs fondamentaux des espèces qui
chassent en meute qui est le soin
parentale était absent chez démonique us
et donc qu'il n'était probablement pas
chasser en meute et de toute façon les
chasseurs en meute nourrissent leur
petit avec le produit de la chasse donc
ou du moins du moins laisse les petits
se nourrir du produit de la chasse après
qu'ils aient mis après qu'ils aient eux
mêmes pris leur part du butin
on va dire donc quoi qu'il arrive on
s'attend chez une espèce qui chassent en
meute à ce que ces deux signature
géochimique soient les mêmes on
s'attendait à ce qu'ils mangent la même
chose or ce n'est pas le cas donc ça
veut dire que dès nonick us ne chassez
pas en groupe
échec et mat la théorie du chasseur en
meute en prend un sale coup et ils ont
même vérifié ils ont poussé le vice
jusqu'à vérifier que les adultes et les
petites et nom taurus avait bien la même
signature géochimique juste pour pas
qu'on puisse dire que cette différence
de signature géochimique est dû au fait
que les petits chasser des petites et
non de sténo taurus il n'y a aucune
raison théorique pour laquelle un bébé
ténontosaure us devrait avoir une
signature chimique différente
qu'on se le dise mais ils ont vérifié la
signature chimique et la même donc petit
ou gros ténontosaure us normalement si
vous mangez du t note aux russes vous
devez avoir la même signature chimique
que l'adulte démonique us donc ça veut
dire pas de soi parentaux pas de partage
pas de partages des proies abattu par le
groupe donc probablement pas de chat son
groupe
parce que parce que ça c'est ce qui se
passe chez toutes les espèces qui
chassent en groupe
aujourd'hui voilà donc au revoir au
revoir au revoir théorie des chasseurs
qui dérape tort qu'ils chassent en
groupe je suis presque sûr que c'est cet
article est tellement passé en dessous
du radar je suis presque sûr que vous en
entendrez encore parler d'aidé drôme et
aux orres qui chassent en groupe pendant
des milliers d'années
je veux dire je suis presque sûr que ça
ne se fera pas mouche et en plus c'est
publié dans une revue qui à bord qui a
un impact factor décent qui qui a une
réputation je dire un peu pâle et aux
trois ça une réputation mais c'est pas
naicker quoi c'est pas nature's et
patience donc je suis sûr que ça va
passer en dessous du radar pour
tellement de monde que vous reverrez des
raptor en train de chasser en groupe
dans le prochain jurassic park
voilà enfin dans le prochain jurassique
world toute façon jurassique world ils
s'en fichent de la science donc bon
suivant alors l'article suivant ça a été
la grande victime du spinosaures pour la
simple et bonne raison que ce pour ce
pauvre ce pauvre article est sorti
exactement le même jour que celui du
spinosaures c'est à dire que encore le
notre article sur les rapts or il n'est
pas encore sorti donc il a encore une
petite chance de faire la une
mais alors celui là celui là vous le
verrez plus jamais et il s'agit de la
description d'un nouveau mammifère qui
s'appelle à dallas terium un mammifère
du crétacé du crétacé terminal de
madagascar et vous voyez ce mammifère
est magnifiquement préservé vous avez
tous la tête le corps les les os de la
patte avant la pâte arias tout est là
tout est là c'est un squelette complet à
100% et il est exceptionnel parce que il
n'ya quasiment pas de fossiles de
de mammifères mésozoïque en afrique
c'est le seul fossiles c'est le seul
squelette complet d'un mammifère
mésozoïque africain et encore il est de
madagascar donc à l'époque c'était pas
madagascar était plus proche de la ddt
à l'époque qu'elle ne l'était de
l'afrique mais en tout cas voilà c'est
donc c'est un squelette qui est assez
exceptionnel et qui appartient à un
groupe dont on ne connaissait aucun
squelette aucun squelette complet qui
s'appelle les gondwana terriens et une
troisième chose qui est intéressante à
propos de ce squelette en plus de ce qui
va pouvoir nous apprendre sur les
gondwana terriens c'est bon déjà il a
une tronche à vous voyez il a des
petites dans des petites dents comme un
rongeur là devant et tout donc il a il a
un profil on va dire et la chose c'est
que il a il aurait enfin vous voyez là
le squelette en vue de côté voyait tout
à l'heure je vous ai montré cette villa
mais c'est de vue là elle montre bien le
elle montre bien le crâne comment le
crâne et est relativement bien préservés
vous voyez il manque juste le haut quoi
donc
il est extrêmement bien préservés et
donc ce qu'il apporte
c'est qu'en fait cet animal est bien il
était relativement lourd donc ils
s'appellent à dallas terium et il pèse 3
kg et il a été trouvé à côté d'un autre
squelette qui avait enfin d'un autre
mammifère qui avait été trouvé quelques
il ya quelques années de cela en 2010 je
crois à madagascar aussi et du crétacé
terminal aussi et qui s'appelle vinh
tana et qui pesait 10 kg donc il y avait
du gros mammifères qui se baladait du
mois d'un point de vue des mammifères
mésozoïque je veux dire on parle de
quelques grammes d'habitude pour les
mammifères mésozoïque et là on avait
quand même du gros mammifères qui se
baladait à madagascar au crétacé
supérieur donc ça ça peut être le signe
de deux choses déjà que les mammifères
étaient en train de prendre de prendre
la confiance quoi à la fin du crétacé
c'est la fin des dinosaures c'est les
mammifères commencent à se diversifier
mais ça veut aussi dire que madagascar
bas c'était une île et que sur les îles
les petites les petits animaux ont
tendance à devenir plus gros et les gros
animaux ont tendance à devenir plus
petits et oui parce que madagascar ça
faisait déjà un bon 10 millions d'années
qu'elle s'était détaché du continent
africain et du continent indien
elle s'est d'abord détaché de l'afrique
puis ensuite elle s'est détachée de
l'awb donc ça faisait un bon 10 millions
d'années qu'elle s'était qu'elle s'était
détaché l'île de madagascar et du coup
ces mammifères insulaires et bien ont
commencé à dériver de leur propre leur
évolution assez mis à dériver et cette
dérive emmène à une évolution a su l'air
qui généralement amène les petits
animaux à devenir gros et les gros
animaux à devenir petit exemple de gros
animaux qui sont devenus petit suite à
une évolution insulaires les zélés enfin
les mammouths ça c'est l'exemple typique
donc après à dallas terium il ya
peut-être une autre raison pour laquelle
il est un peu passé inaperçu c'est
précisément parce que on avait déjà
découvert binh thanh a donc finalement
et ventana est un très très proche
parent d'adalah terium sauf qu'il a sauf
qu'il a une tronche encore plus bizarre
line thanh haï là il a les mêmes
caractères qu'à dallas terium est encore
plus prononcée donc les dents les
incisives de devant sont encore plus
grosses la petite bosse qu'il a sur la
joue et encore plus grosse aide à lâcher
ventana et puis évidemment le l'animal
lui-même est encore plus gros donc ça
peut donc la seule différence entre
finalement entre ventana et à dallas
terium scada la terium ajoute en fait à
l'équation c'est le squelette complet
donc c'est petit c'est peut-être aussi
une autre raison pour laquelle cette
découverte et a passé un peu plus
inaperçu que qu'elle ne l'aurait dû
c'est parce que c'est parce que
finalement elle apporte pas peu de
choses mais le squelette finalement il
n'est pas assez bien des enfin il est
passé complètement décrit dans cette
publication le squelette pour que
vraiment ça ça amène une grosse
plus-value
et puis pour ventana il avait aussi pris
le temps de décrire le cerveau et c'est
donc là ils n'ont pas de cerveau
préserver vu que la boîte crânienne a
complètement disparu l'oreille interne
aussi elle est complètement écrasée donc
finalement ils ont moins d'informations
sur le crâne et ils ont plus
d'informations sur les sur les oppose
crânien donc sur le squelette que et il
donne pas de suffisamment d'informations
sur le squelette pour que ça amène une
grosse plus-value de ce point de vue là
donc la grosse plus value c'est juste la
théorie sur l'évolution insulaires des
des gondwana terriens et puis il ya
aussi la phylogénie qui est relativement
intéressante puisqu'elle place les
gondwana teria très près des multi
tuberculés est aussi très près des
adieux à rama ida qui généralement les
amarres à idées généralement ils sont
placés tout à la base des malheurs forme
donc on sait pas trop comment mais ça
les a tirés vers le haut d'un seul coup
de de rajouter à dallas terium donc en
gros ça cette phylogénie nous rappelle
que les mammifères mésozoïque était
beaucoup plus diverse que les mammifères
d'aujourd'hui parce que les mammifères
d'aujourd'hui celle et placentaires les
marsupiaux et puis un petit peu de mots
notres aime tout petit peu de mots
notres m
alors que mésozoïque vous aviez des
mains des placentaires des marsupiaux
vous avez le clad décimé trop de honte
vous aviez les multis tubercules et les
gondwana terre les eaux rama yade et
vous aviez déjà les mots notres m qui
étaient là vous avez ce clad qui
s'appelle les do conde honte et vous
avez vous avez d'autres trucs ici qui
n'ont pas de famille mais qui sont
représentent des lignes est tout seul
donc voilà au mésozoïque y avait du
monde beaucoup plus de monde donc même
s'il ressent même si pour nous ils
ressemblaient tous juste à des rongeurs
ou ad ou à des des musaraignes ben en
fait j'avais beaucoup beaucoup plus de
diversité du point de vue génétique à
l'époque qu'il n'y en a maintenant
finalement article suivant l'article
suivant est un article que vraiment qui
aurait vraiment mérité qu'on le voit
celui là parce qu'il est super
intéressant c'est la première analyse du
génome complet de lion des cavernes un
génome complet de lion des cavernes des
fossiles qui ont trente mille ans trente
mille ans et ils ont fait une analyse
complète du génome ça veut dire ils
n'ont pas juste prix à fragments des
gènes ou juste l'adn mitochondrial non
ils ont le génome entier quoi des
millions et des millions de paires de
base donc c'est une analyse qui est
absolument prodigieuse donc voilà ils
ont ils ont elles un échantillon de lion
des cavernes de sibérie est un qui vient
d'alaska et enfin du yukon pas vraiment
à l'aise comme bon c c'est juste à côté
et le principe elle-même préservation
dans la glace qui permet de conserver de
l'adn et ils ont fait cette analyse
phylogénétique donc à partir du génome
entier qui montre déjà
que les donc leno lion des cavernes ils
sont là et donc il montre déjà que les
lion des cavernes sont bel et bien plus
proche des lions modernes qu'ils ne le
sont du léopard ce qui fait que le ce
qui fait qu'ils appartiennent bien à
l'espèce panthera leo
voilà déjà ceci dit ils sont
complètement distincts de de pantera des
panthères aller au moderne
donc ils s'ajustent y fit finalement la
classification panthera leo ce pda
donc le lion des cavernes littéralement
donc déjà ça c'est intéressant on a
enfin on a finalement la position
phylogénétique confirmé 2d lion des
cavernes et aux six bases du coup ça
nous donne un groupe externe qui nous
permet d'orienter beaucoup mieux la
phylogénie des lions moderne parce que
quand vous utilisez le léopard vous
utilisez un âge de divergence qui est à
plusieurs millions d'années un ou deux
millions d'années alors que quand vous
utilisez le lion des cavernes pas votre
âge de divergences il remonte à
seulement 500 mille ans donc votre
groupe externe est beaucoup plus
pertinent on va dire pour orienter
l'évolution de vos de votre groupe
interne à savoir les lions si vous
n'êtes pas familier avec le concept de
groupes externes et de groupes internes
vous allez voir ma vidéo sur le
marsupilami je fais ma propre pub est ce
qu'il ya d'intéressant du coup c'est que
en ayant des génomes entiers et en ayant
ce nouveau groupe externe et bien il
trouve un pattern intéressant c'est
qu'en fait les lions d'asie
et oui il y a des lions en asie encore
aujourd'hui il ya une petite population
qui vit encore aujourd'hui en inde
ils sont pas en terre entièrement
disparu ça va pas tarder mais ils sont
présents que dans un seul dans une seule
réserve naturelle donc ça va vraiment
pas traîné mais voilà les lions d'asie
ici en bleu sont plus proches parents
des lions d'afrique de l'ouest et de
l'afrique du nord donc les lions de
l'atlas que ces lions d'afrique ne le
sont d autres lions qu'on retrouve en
partout ailleurs en afrique
donc en fait les lions en verre ici et
en violet ici sont plus proches parents
des lions en bleu
là alors que les airs et d'ailleurs les
lions en bleus là ne sont pas du tout
proche parent avec les lions qu'on
trouve juste à côté en asie aussi là et
de l'autre côté bon s'était connecté à
l'époque ou plus ou moins là donc en
fait on trouve vraiment un patron de
variation phylogénétique assez
intéressant quoi et du coup et ça ça a
des répercussions sur la conservation
c'est donc on sait que les lions
d'afrique du nord les lions de l'atlas
ont complètement disparu donc ça c'est
des populations qui n'existe plus
aujourd'hui
mais du coup maintenant qu'on sait que
les lions de l'atlas sont plus proches
des lions d'afrique de l'ouest aussi eh
ben ça va ça permet et sachant qu'il en
reste des lions en afrique de l'ouest
parce que les lions les zones en gris
ici ce sont les les zones de
distribution de des lions actuelle et si
vous voyez qu'il ya un petit patch en
gris foncé là donc c'est lions d'afrique
de l'ouest en fait on le meilleur pool
génétique pour réintroduire des lions en
afrique en afrique du nord et même et
c'est lyon ces mêmes lions qu'on trouve
en afrique de l'ouest et en afrique du
nord aurait le meilleur pool génétique
pour pouvoir réintroduire des lions en
asie si jamais on en avait besoin
donc ça aussi des implications sur la
conservation et ça c'est un des
magnifiques un magnifique exemple de ce
que la paléontologie peut nous aider à
mieux gérer les les espèces modernes
le dernier article de ce paléo news ça
va être un article sur l'évolution
humaine
un article d'une élégance incroyable
donc je recommande dont je recommande la
lecture même s'il est un peu compliqué à
comprendre
mais il est d'une grande grande élégance
donc c'est un article qui discutent en
fait de l'ancêtre commun entre
néandertal et l'homo sapiens est de
savoir en fait pas si il est plutôt
africains ou s'il est plutôt
eurasiatique
alors pour ça ils ont construit trois
modèles donc enfin du moins ils ont
testé trois modèles donc le premier
modèle c'est que l'ancêtre commun de
homo sapiens et de homo neandertalensis
vivait il y a en gros un million
d'années et descend de quelque chose qui
ressemblait à homo erectus
voilà donc c'est pas forcément homo
erectus il l'appelle peurs liées aux
mots ça peut être agacé terre aussi mais
voilà ça ce serait quelque chose qui
ressemblait à homo erectus ou ergaster
est donc selon ce modèle là il y aurait
un âge de divergences à un million
d'années
et vous auriez la lignée hanter ses
soeurs et d'albert guentis néandertal n
6 qui aurait donné néandertal et vous
auriez l'autre ligne et rhodésienne 6 de
l'autre côté qui aurait donné au mot sa
place donc rhodésie m6 c'est le crâne de
kabou et celui de du zimbabwe et de
zambie pardon dont on avait parlé dans
le dernier paléo news il ya un autre
scénario qui dit que romo en tc sort en
fait c'est le groupe frère de néandertal
denisova bon denisot veille l'intègre
pas dans leurs études donc c'est le
groupe frère de néandertal et de sapiens
et que donc l'ancêtre commun était un
était tanné de halberg n 6 soient d'asie
soient d'afrique
donc là on serait on serait un peu on
sera un peu le cul entre deux chaises
puisqu'on ne serait pas sûr que ce soit
et de le berghain six africains ou
asiatiques et la troisième hypothèse et
on aurait une divergence 0.7 million
d'années et ensuite on aurait un dernier
scénario où on aurait un ancêtre
africain typiquement africa de
heidelberg m6 africains qui serait
l'ancêtre commun de neandertal et homo
sapiens et cet ancêtre il aurait vécu il
y à seulement 400 mille ans donc avec
juste le registre fossile qu'on a on
serait plutôt tenté de favoriser ce
modèle là puisque le plus vieux homo
sapiens qu'on a il a trois cent mille
ans le plus vieux néandertal con là il a
quatre cent mille ans donc avec le
registre fossile qu'on a on serait tenté
de favoriser celui-là oui mais si en tc
sort et tout ce qu'on appelle les prix
en herbe néandertaliens sont bel et bien
les ancêtres de néanderthal bas on peut
repousser au moins lancer les ancêtres
de néanderthal jusqu'à jusqu'à plusieurs
jusqu'à au moins un million d'années
voire même plus pourquoi pas donc
jusqu'à au moins 600 mille ans en tout
cas et pourquoi pas même à vous voir
plus de millions d'années que ça et si
on
et puis ce scénario du milieu là lui il
est plutôt avantagé par les analyses
génétiques notamment une analyse
génétique qui a été réalisé il n'y a pas
si longtemps que ça
équipe la santé ces sorts comme groupe
frère de denisova et sa place donc les
analyses génétiques
elle elle irait plutôt dans le sens de
placer en tc sort en groupe frère de
néandertal et sapiens donc on a trois
scénarios qui 2 qui colle du avec avec
le registre fossile mais dépendant de la
façon dont on l'interprète est un qui
colle avec une analyse génétique récente
donc finalement si on devait juste
s'arrêter là on ne saurait pas trop sur
quel pied danser donc eu ce qu'ils ont
fait du coup c'est qu'ils ont utilisé un
procédé qui s'appelle d landmark et de
la géométrie morpho métriques 3d ils ont
placé ces landmark vous voyez partout
sur le crâne vous en avez des en rouge
mais faut voir aussi celles qui sont en
crise là il y en a des centaines la
hongrie donc ils ont grâce à ces
landmark sur des reconstitutions en 3d
des crânes ou sur les crânes directement
digitalisées enfin numérisés si vous
préférez donc ils ont numérisé les
crânes par scanner et ils ont placé ces
landmark dessus pour pouvoir quantifier
en fait la forme du crâne et en
quantifiant la forme du crâne
ça leur a permis de créer ce qu'on
appelle des analyses à composante
principale c'est-à-dire ce graphe dire
qu'il faut vous imaginer que tout c'est
tout c'est landmark tous ces poids qui
sont posées sur les crânes ce sont des
données et l'ensemble de ces données
vous donne un jeu de données et ce jeu
de données il est gigantesque puis vous
vous imaginez qu elle est coordonnée de
tous les points surtout les crânes donc
ces accords c'est un jeu de données qui
est gigantesque et l'analyse en
composante principale elle vous permet
de représenter ce jeu de données sur un
graphe en deux dimensions
donc il vous simplifie énormément la
tâche
vous n'imaginez même pas donc je
pourrais essayer de vous expliquer
comment ça marche ça prendrait des
heures et
je vous dirais probablement n'importe
quoi ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'en
gros vous avez toutes ses coordonnées de
tous ces points les rouges et les
grilles pour chaque crâne qui l'ont
analysée et qui est retranscrit en
l'analysant composante principale
c'est-à-dire en sur deux axes après vous
pouvez choisir de regarder plus dax vous
pouvez regarder la kz numéro 3 avec ce
numéro 4 il ya plein dax dans une
analyse en composante principale il ya
plein de composantes principales
justement mai mais bon ce plus on
rajoute dax et plus on enlève l'élégance
en fait de la chose l'élégance de la
chose c'est d'avoir cette partir d'un
jeu de données qui est incompréhensible
pour un cerveau humain est de finir avec
juste un graphe qu'on peut lire comme ça
voilà d'un graphe en 2d tout bête
donc c'est ça l'élégance donc déjà ça la
technique utilisée est élégante mais en
plus ce qui est élégant c'est que ils
ont dit j enfin ils ont dit j tease et
je parle anglais angle franglais ils ont
numérisé donc des crânes d'hommes de
néanderthal et ils ont numérisé des
crânes d'homo sapiens la plupart moderne
mais aussi quelques crânes fossiles dont
on est sûr de l'attribution notamment
ceux de de kabze et de skull qui sont de
crâne d'homo sapiens confirmés qui
viennent qui viennent de du moyen-orient
est ici vous avez pareil des crânes de
néandertal confirmés c'est à dire qu'on
touche pas à ce niveau-là ce qu'ils ont
fait à ce niveau là en fait c'est qu'ils
n'ont absolument pas toucher pour
l'instant
oh oh oh fossiles d'hommes de ba2 qu'on
a vu tout à l'heure c'est à dire les
heurts liés au mot les hanter ses sorts
les ailes de bergen 6les rhodésienne 6
tout ça il y touche pas eu ce qu'ils
veulent c'est regarder les crânes de
néandertal purée de sapiens pure et
après ça ils vont reconstituer grâce à
l'analyse en composantes principales
l'ancêtre commun
ce à quoi l'ancêtre commun devait
ressembler et ça c'est ça c'est beau ça
c'est très très beau c'est très très
élégant parce que quand vous projetez en
fait ce qu'ils ont fait c'est qu'ils ont
donc fait leur analyse en composantes
principales miller crâne voilà donc là
vous avez les homos
les homos heurts liés aux mots là vous
avez sapia cela vous avez néandertal est
en fait ils ont projeté la phylogénie
par dessus cette cette analyse en
composantes principales de telle façon à
connecter les points d qui correspondent
à chaque spécimen de la même façon que
si c'était une phylogénie en fait
et du coup ça leur indique que l'ancêtre
commun envoyé l'endroit où les trois
branches convergent
ça veut dire que l'ancêtre commun il est
là un point qui correspond à des
coordonnées bien précise sur l'analyse
en composantes principales et du coup ça
veut dire que ça correspond à des cordes
ça veut dire que vous pouvez retraduire
ça en coordonnées de crâne
donc vous pouvez reconvertir cet ancêtre
commun hypothétique reconstruit sur
l'analyse en composante principale à
partir de la phylogénie vous pouvez leur
traduire encore donné deux points sur
encore donné deux points sur un crâne
hypothétique et du coup vous pouvez re
construire un crâne entier complètement
virtuel et ce crâne entier complètement
virtuel représente un ancêtre commun et
hugues où ils ont fait ça avec les trois
hypothèses que je vous ai montré thaler
l'ancêtre commun récent l'ancêtre commun
très vieux et d'ancêtres communs moyens
ils ont fait ça trois fois pour
reconstruire trois ans être comme un
hypothétique danser ce qu'on voit là
l'ancêtre commun
le récent moyen est très vieux et ça
leur a donné des reconstitutions du coup
dans de ce que de ce à quoi d'ancêtre
commun devait ressembler donc en fait
c'est quasiment du rétro ingénierie hng
quoi c'est du rétro engineering de crâne
de d'ancêtre commun de sapiens et de
néandertal est là où ça devient
formidable c'est qu'on peut ensuite
comparé ces crânes reconstitué avec les
vrais crâne qu'on a donc les vrais crâne
dans tc sort des deux leberg n 6 et 2 et
et deux heures liés au mot et plein
d'autres crâne qui sont pas attribués
comme celui des crânes d'ancêtres d'homo
sapiens comme djebel est rude ou des
crânes voilà de près néandertaliens on
peut comparer tous ces crânes à plein
d'autres à plein d'autres crâne qui
n'ont pas été inclus dans l'analyse est
comme ça et comme ça ça nous permet de
tester finalement ces hypothèses
laquelle des trois hypothèses qu'on a vu
au début et la bonne laquelle à un crâne
reconstitué qui correspond à quelque
chose qui existe vraiment c'est énorme
c'est ultra élégant c'est juste et ça
paraît simple mais il fallait y penser
non c'est pas simple mais c'est pas
simple du tout mais je veux dire une
fois qu'on a compris le principe on se
dit bah oui c'est waouh c'est waouh donc
trois hypothèses trois crânes
reconstitué voyons voir maintenant
lequel est le bon
et donc pour voir lequel est le bon bah
ils ont projeté finalement ils ont
refait une analyse en composante
principale alors une pour l'arrière du
crâne et une pour la face parce qu'ils
n'ont pas poussé le vice jusqu'à
reconstituer la face et l'arrière du
crâne en même temps ça aurait pu être
marrant et donc ce qu'on a et va c'est
que quand on regarde que l'arrière du
crâne le l'ancêtre commun récent il
tombe au milieu des espèces africaines
qui sont ici en noir et là vous avez les
espèces eurasia eurasiatique en gris
vous avez toujours les heurts liés aux
mots donc les homo erectus ergaster et
tout ça ils sont toujours en vert vous
avez toujours les néandertal en rouge et
vous avez toujours non je crois que
c'est les sapiens les sapiens en rouge
elles et néandertal en bleu attendez je
vais vérifier je perds vérifier parce
que je peux pas dire de bêtises ouais
c'est ça les néandertal en bleu et les
sapiens sont rouges
vous avez les néandertaliens bleus les
sapiens en rouge
or les homos en gris vous en gris foncé
enfin en noir en point noir dans un
carré gris foncé vous avez les les
les homos de les homos possible sapiens
heldenbergh n 6 euros des yens 6 mai qui
ont été découverts en afrique en gros et
en gris
vous avez les possibles homo sapiens de
leurs yens 6 ans tc sort tout ça kipré
néandertaliens qui ont été découverts en
eurasie donc en fait ça fait pas du tout
de la raison pour laquelle je galère là
c'est parce que du coup cette graphie
fait pas du tout de d'hypothèses quant à
l'attribution de ces crânes
ils font il fait juste il reflète juste
leur origine géographique donc donc ça
n'a pas d'importance de savoir quoi ils
représentent l'important c'est de savoir
la façon dont ils sont quantifiées donc
donc ils ont quantifié tous ces crânes
de la même façon qu'ils ont fait pour
les pour les autres ceux de sapiens et
néandertal et du coup quand on les met
tous ensemble avec les ancêtres
reconstitué et ben ça nous montre que
les trois ans être reconstitué il tombe
dans la variation en fait dans les
coordonnées des crânes africains donc là
vous reconnaissez l'homo sapiens de hiru
d'
vous avez aux modeuses qui est un qui
est archaïque homo sapiens vous avez qu
à bout et qui est homo rhodésienne 6l
h16 je suppose et singa je suis pas sûr
de ce que c'est c'est probablement
d'heidelberg n 6 donc voilà vous avez il
tombe dans les ancêtres africains
voilà est là quand vous regardez la face
maintenant avec la face le graff est un
peu plus gros en plus c'est plus facile
à lire
vous avez reliés aux mots vous avez
néandertal vous avez sapiens en rouge
vous avez les les homos pléistocène les
homos du pléistocène en noir et vous
avez les homos asiatique en gris et vous
avez l'ancêtre commun le plus ancien qui
enfin l'ancêtre commun reconstituer
suivant l'hypothèse où il serait très
anciens où ils seraient vieux d'un
million d'années qui se retrouvent dans
la gamme de variation des homos africain
vous avez l'ancêtre commun d'un
intermédiaire qui se trouve aussi dans
la gamme des africains et vous avez
l'ancêtre commun le plus récent qui se
retrouvent dans la gamme de variation
des asiatiques
donc selon l'une des donc selon l'une si
on regarde à la si on regarde plutôt
l'arrière du crâne
on a tous ou presque qui tombe
la gamme tout ce qui tombe dans la gamme
de variation des ancêtres africains avec
le plus récent qui est quand même plus
du côté eurasiatique et si on regarde
que la phase là on a les deux ancêtres
les plus anciens qui tombent
définitivement dans la gamme de
variation des défauts si l'africain est
le plus récent qui tombe plutôt dans la
gamme de variation des des fossiles
asiatiques
donc maintenant si on revient à notre
hypothèse de base à nos trois hypothèses
de base et ben ça on voit que déjà là ça
colle pas avec le modèle 3 le modèle 3
prédit que l'ancêtre commun suivant
l'hypothèse où il serait très récent
devrait être un et deux libériennes 6
africa donc pousse pousse déjà ce modèle
là n'est pas validé puisque les données
ne colle pas finalement à ce qu'on
attend de l'hypothèse donc les deux
hypothèses qui tiennent le mieux c'est
les hypothèses qui prévoit que l'ancêtre
commun et soit descendu d'un heurts liés
aux mots peut-être d'un homo erectus
soit que l'ancêtre commun étaient tannés
de l'albertaine six africains et du coup
qui indiquent qu'il serait africain
l'hypothèse ne faisait pas tellement de
ne prenez pas tellement de la géographie
à défaut pour le coup mais voilà pour le
cool ce que ce qu'indiquent les graphes
c'est que cet ancêtre étaient plutôt
africains et que donc après et de
bergues n 6 s'est dispersé en asie pour
donner naissance à néanderthal n 6 et
donc en tc sort dans cette hypothèse
serait plus banal que néandertal m6 et
sa place et on s'est du coup et on sait
que cette hypothèse là est soutenu par
une analyse phylogénétique récente de
l'adn de homo antecessor et on sait par
ailleurs que cette hypothèse là je veux
dire c'est pas parce que le plus ancien
des homo sapiens à 300 mille ans qui on
pourrait pas en trouver a aussi vieux
que six cent mille ans pourquoi pas donc
finalement c'est le
les deux arbres les plus probables et
deux hypothèses les plus probables c'est
la numéro de la numéro 3 est là et et
finalement si on si on ne fait que s'en
tenir aux données fossiles et génétique
on pourrait dire que celle ci est plus
probable que les autres du coup c'est un
magnifique exemple de comment on pose
trois hypothèses
comment on utilise les données digitales
les données numérisées pardon pour
reconstituer la morphologie d'un ancêtre
ans comme de trois ans être en commun
suivant ces trois hypothèses et ensuite
on les compare aux fossiles toujours on
les dit on et en les numérisant en
utilisant une technique de afin de
quantifier leur morphologie on les
compare aux fossiles et on regarde la
quelle hypothèse colle le mieux à ce
qu'on obtient etc et je veux dire là où
c'est hyper élégance et qui a aucune
raison pour les enfin je veux dire si si
on tient vraiment à être ultra
sceptiques avec ça à la base on pourrait
se dire il ya aucune raison pour
laquelle un ancêtre commun complètement
hypothétique reconstitué à partir de
néandertal et sapiens a aucune raison
que ça ressemble à quoi que ce soit et
en fait si le fait est qu en le faisant
il retrouve que ça ressemble à des
fossiles qui existe vraiment le dire vvl
ca il ressemble par exemple beaucoup au
crâne de cabot et qu'on avait vu dans le
dernier paléo news voilà donc ils vont
cesser d'une élégance assez remarquable
donc on a maintenant des données
morphologiques et génétiques qui vont
dans le sens de cette hypothèse là
voilà c'était paléo news je vous
remercie de l'avoir suivi abonnez vous
pour ne rien manquer d'anciens et à très
bientôt
[Musique]